son algunos de los últimos refugiados
rojillas que desembarcaron en la
provincia de asec en Indonesia
174 personas en total llegaron a la
costa local y varios reciben tratamiento
tras sufrir deshidratación severa fueron
instalados temporalmente en terrenos de
una escuela secundaria aunque aún no
está claro Cuánto tiempo duró la
travesía uno de los jóvenes Indicó que
procedían de un campo de refugiados en
bangladesh
en bangladesh nuestra vida era difícil
incluso teníamos prohibido trabajar y
los niños no podían ir al colegio
escolar todos los años miles de rugins
perseguidos por la mayoría budista de
myanmar arriesgan sus vidas en el mar
con frecuencia en embarcaciones
peligrosas en las que intentan llegar a
Malasia o Indonesia
dejamos bangladesh porque mis padres ya
no están vivos y yo no podía casarme ni
recibir educación somos pobres Así que
vinimos aquí los desembarcos en esta
región se han vuelto más frecuentes
con frecuencia debatimos las razones de
Por qué tantos barcos rojillas
desembarcan en hacer
uno de los muchos factores es el
geográfico que hace que los barcos se
queden varados y puedan desembarcar
otros 57 rojillas llegaron a hacer el 25
de diciembre y otros 230 más lo hicieron
en noviembre en sri lanka a principios
de diciembre las autoridades rescataron
también a 104 personas y las tailandesas
a otras 6 la creciente represión en mi
al mar contra esta minoría hace que cada
vez más de sus integrantes se lancen al
mar como vía de escape